you are entering a zone that most people
are scared to enter do not be scared if
you're under 18 hang up now if you're
above the age 18 you're gonna go to
places that you've only dreamed about in
your [ __ ] mind you understand me when
you get together with your little
[ __ ] [ __ ] friends and they tell you
oh my god I got to honey
you
you could never get too high understand
baby
uncle Joey here recovering from [ __ ]
Monday night Church as you could tell my
balls are still shocking [ __ ] sometimes
you see the devil name no [ __ ] coming
back 900 milligrams some [ __ ]
torturous read from bondage the Jerry's
kids it's tough to recover but you know
what uncle Joey's here to come home and
drink some [ __ ] I mean kid juice and
sleep I woke up like a [ __ ] doctor
whether you take over the world they got
a 10 o'clock I got a 12 o'clock and that
dinner at 6:00 I got a spot slap is at
11:00
I'll be doing spots of flappers just to
cover my [ __ ] special told I want to
be ready for you mother [ __ ] Savage
so give me a minute and we take the hit
on the pipe of life
it's all over the [ __ ] building so I
gotta go get it gonna show that I have a
work with a paperclip my [ __ ] house
water reaches the understanding but I
don't give a [ __ ]
water weakness get stolen jack
my smoke
Larry's og from perennial in other words
aka mom would if they waited they just
bought this the [ __ ] alligator from
businesses that's exactly this life this
eat you up will [ __ ] live you
understand me
one minute you smoking dope the next my
job the water fail what the [ __ ] is
wrong I should have stayed home and
played [ __ ] Parcheesi anyway there's
our [ __ ] we're here it's Tuesday and
that's all that [ __ ] matters mostly
you get up it's - it's [ __ ] Tuesday
it's another thing to stab a
[ __ ] understanding it's another
day to stake your claim and let these
[ __ ] Gentiles know who's running [ __ ]
[Music]
what are you gonna do walk on coals well
you may go walking coals to express
myself I hate you [ __ ] that
need books right yourself you want to
express yourself and get run over by a
[ __ ] car people remember you for
three weeks
until then you smoke this [ __ ] reefer
you [ __ ] next move
and it's over they can't stop you every
day's a [ __ ] thought you wake up you
go you know what the blizzards are
people getting stabbed I don't give a
[ __ ] it's a beautiful better be alive
you could say this as you're walking
over the [ __ ] bodies is it to your
mind that really starts in your mind
understand
like that then you solidify it with this
you write it on paper who's gonna stop
looking come on you're smoking dope with
a robot like a [ __ ] doctor I'm saying
most people should get their dicks up
with a rope I met uncle Joey I'm smoking
dope with you [ __ ] what do you
think [ __ ] great I went up to Seattle
second row just a joke we talked about
let's hit this [ __ ] soldier you
absolutely right I'm still got [ __ ]
flashbacks from last night know what I'm
saying you can't [ __ ] charge me for
this [ __ ] anyway I'm just trying to get
the day started with you [ __ ]
keep the cops low some fruit BAM I go
eat nice two eggs with [ __ ] weak
toast and that's it that's my day people
I'm in the struggle just like you every
[ __ ] day all these cars
ah but the key is you don't quit you
keep showing up then I don't know what
to do it
I'm the worst that you do behind the
world but I keep showing up and every
day I'm go strong that my arm gets
strong
I can do my stuff up and push up you
know whatever who gives a [ __ ] as long
as you keep showing up eventually they
don't have to get thick that's it that's
what life's all about
keep showing up I think that's [ __ ]
honest I keep showing about here smoking
weed with you people but I keep showing
up that's the [ __ ] name of the game
I told you no flutters I'm strong for
the guilty Annapolis but what do you get
my Crockett now we had an accident we
came out we tried to get together the
Sun hit me the reefer hit me in a weird
way we had an accident what the [ __ ]
what on a meeting and get a hug and a
free cup of coffee son quite big
we're uncle Joey with a church and this
damn we don't tap we don't stop we keep
going till we get shot in the [ __ ]
head and even then your eyes are
blinking so that's it
what we learn from my little dates
update another day the suck your dick
and don't forget to eat your vegetables
exercise as we speak [ __ ] hold on for
that [ __ ] patch in your stomach
get your kidneys your liver everybody's
[ __ ] high understand bye
I am so proud module or a much more than
I like everything completed but worry
about waiting hunt if I wanted okay
I mean if I easily recognizable casino
after having hello hello people didn't
your mama tell opinio yes all of my
importantly don't say
keep your eye on this [ __ ] always
remember at the end they got a son get
there and with that I gotta take two
steps to the rear in Galilee I gotta go
wash my [ __ ] I gotta go [ __ ] get
ready for the day or I gotta make notes
I just wanna let you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart
same thing stopping us today listen even
if we give up they'll never win
alright just think of it that way
I'm feeling dead top today I'm smoking
the weed [ __ ] Anthony Rapp and smoked
before you tell those people don't walk
walk on those cold cuts something you
dumb [ __ ] and that's it I love you
[ __ ] I'll see you tomorrow
night with the church I don't know what
time I got [ __ ] to do I'm not even
thinking about it right now but you know
I love you guys have a great day
tell them all to suck your dick I'm
strolling to the gills stay black